c'est une des urgences les plus
surchargées au Québec en ce moment on a
50 patients couchés sur civières donc on
est à 166%
contribue et si je suis à 1 j'ai un lit
par 1000 mais le 6 de monter régie Ouest
se démène pour éviter l'asphyxie un
département d'hospitalisation a été
fermé pour agrandir l'urgence faute
d'espace suffisant le défi est surtout
de permettre au patient de retourner
rapidement à domicile pour libérer délit
on a pu trouver des médecins qui ont
enlevé la main pour prendre en charge
des patients dans les soins à domicile
mais c'est clair et certain que ça ça va
être la voie qu'on doit prioriser
l'hospitalisation à la maison
l'établissement Innov le personnel
travail de plus en plus mais les
hôpitaux ou de l'ouest de la Montérégie
lutte à contre-courant
inondé par cette population là qui est
proportionnée par rapport à notre
capacité que c'est comme si tous nos
résultats sont masqués les nez secourus
au début de notre visite a été sauvé une
petite victoire qui serait impossible
sans le temps supplémentaire qui ici est
presque la norme on tient le coup je
pense qu'on est une super de belle
équipe puis c'est ce qui fait qu'on
reste en fait parce que on a quand même
pensé à quitter le navire quelquefois
mais
on est une belle équipe
le personnel espère que les
rassemblements de Noël ne provoqueront
pas d'afflux de patients grippés parce
que le seul véritable répit viendra avec
l'inauguration d'un nouvel hôpital dans
la région en 2026 ici David Canada
Valley